der russische oppositionelle alexej
nawalny sitzt seit seiner rückkehr nach
russland im januar in haft
zuvor hatte er sich von einer vergiftung
in deutschland erholt in einer
strafkolonie östlich von moskau ist er
zuletzt in den hungerstreik getreten
sein team wirft der regierung
misshandlungen und schikane vor
wir haben mittlerweile stabschef
gesprochen
es geht hält sich schlecht er ist krank
und wir verstehen nicht was für eine
krankheit das ist weil kein arzt ist
zugelassen
im besichtigen deshalb ist da auch auf
dem grundstück für 14 tage schon weil er
eigentlich verlangt dass da eine normale
herzliche behandeln bekommt diese
bekommt er doch noch nicht und wir
wissen eigentlich nicht was mit ihm
passiert sogar wissen die symptome mit
beine und arme leben und das aus einem
bein schon nahezu nicht bewegen kann
aber wir wissen nicht die diagnose
sein leben ist in gefahr dass es jetzt
für uns ganz klar das system ist sehr
grausam gegen mich hin und er wird alles
gemacht um ihm zu quellen um sein leben
im gefängnis miserabel zu machen und wir
sind auch ganz sicher dass sich dass das
auf dem direkten befehl von vom
präsidenten putin passiert
alles was mit alexei passiert ist alles
ausnahme das passiert alles nicht
laut gesetzen nicht laut regeln
angefangen mit der verhaftung im
flughafen und dann mit einem gericht
sitzung in einer polizeistation und
alles was danach passiert hat mit mit
diesem stündlichen wecken und mit allen
quellen deinen gefängnis das ist alles
so untypisch für apple will russland das
das nur mit einer kann steuerung
erklären sind kennt und natürlich im
fall wally so eine handsteuerung 0 für
von einem von von einer hand stammt kam
das ist vor allem ganz klar
die einzige möglichkeit informationen zu
kriegen ist durch die verteidiger montag
bis freitag sind die verteidiger zumal
ich sie zugelassen schriftlich kennen
wir nicht kommunizieren aber die
verteidiger können immer etwas sagen
natürlich auch in anwesenheit von
[Musik]
aus dem system so das soll auch
irgendwie eine sprache sprechen würden
aber doch können die verteidiger eine
falsche informationen an alex silva
weiterleiten und alexej darf auch etwas
sagen und zum beispiel seine instagram
posten diktieren
wir planen jetzt größere demonstrationen
wahrscheinlich mitte oder der anfang
oder mitte mai wenn wir 500.000 kröte
die ist in ihrem kölner de
die sich bewerben in diesen
demonstrationen teilzunehmen das machen
wird damit wir die individuellen risiken
für für jeden teilnehmer geringer machen
können das ist ganz wichtig weil jetzt
das geht es um serve viele polizeiliche
brutalität gegen die teilnehmer der
demonstration viele leute würden
verhaftet oder können aus den
arbeitsplatz verlieren oder bekommen sie
sehr hohe geldbußen usw
die einzige möglichkeit die
individuellen risiken zu verkleinern
besteht dann dass es ist es so möglich
so viel wie möglich löste teilzunehmen
und in breiteren politischen kontext ist
das natürlich sehr wichtig dass wir in
diesem jahr parlamentswahlen haben die
duma wahlen im september
und das ist ja dass das ist das
höhepunkt des politischen in russland im
letzten jahren und wir vorbereiten muss
sehr stark auf diese parlament wollen so
haben unsere kandidaten und wir
unterstützen auch die kandidaten von
anderen parteien die die wahlen in
seinem wahlbezirken gegen die taliban
von putins partei die vereinigte
russland gewinnen können